Peter King NBC sports.com and the great
column starting your Monday morning
football morning in America spent some
time at the combine feels like it's
Groundhog Day Peter people go kicking
and screaming yours included with the
combine that we don't really get much
out of this and then after it we're
talking about those who are rising and
falling and who made money and you know
so all the drama that was their number
one story number one headline coming out
of the combine is what for you
unfortunately because I don't know that
there's anything altogether new but you
know I'm having breakfast with somebody
very prominent in the league got
Thursday and I said give me your stories
this week and he goes Tom Brady is the
Domino that's paralyzing the entire NFL
you know until people know what happens
there look at how many people are being
held hostage you know from from Sirte
from Derek Carr to to Bill Belichick to
I don't I mean just there's 30 really
big people in the NFL who their lives
are going to be affected an awful lot by
whatever Tom Brady chooses to do and
whatever teams choose to go after them
now there are some teams that are out
there who are quote in the Tom Brady
hunt
end quote that I'm not sure that they
are but and there's some teams that I
think it really doesn't make a lot of
sense for but who knows this is a very
unusual situation the reason I put only
a little bit there is that you know the
rest of the league is going on and and
you know there's an awful lot happening
this is this is the combine really has
become like a political convention
because everybody and I mean everybody
goes for four or five days and so you're
going to run into Jerry Jose you're
going to rent you're going to rent a
house Roseman you're going to rent it to
preserve you run into everybody in the
lead at some point over like a four day
period if you're lucky and get this
schmooze a little bit move on the
difference I think this year dance is
this the labor agreement although
the public and rightfully so is not all
that concerned about it because no
matter what happens there is going to be
football this year but the labor
agreement is on everybody's life that is
it you know to the common person in the
NFL so much more important than where
Tom Brady leans and I had I had the
Giants player rep a Nate's older tell me
over the weekend that he asked 15
players on his team in the last few days
he's parked 15 players and he said what
would your Oakley do you want to say if
16 games are go to 17 with improved
salary and benefits and he goes through
is 15 to nothing in favor of playing 17
games so there's a tremendous disparity
of opinion it is exactly I said to
somebody this is precisely like the
America that Donald Trump sees and the
America that Bernie Sanders seats in
just diametrically opposed and
somebody's going to be really pissed off
with this quizes mode happen and maybe a
thousand people be really kicked off but
this is going to be a very interesting
story over the next week or so what's
more likely to happen Brady leaves the
Patriots or the Redskins take TOA at
number 2 the Redskins are taken to it I
you know I just can't I can't see it in
a million years now is it in their best
interest to convince everybody that they
might take to it yes because then Miami
might be forced or you know I mean
imagine this scenario did imagine Miami
trades a 1 and a 2 to go up to number 2
to get you know to get to make sure they
get to us and then imagine the the the
magical Washington then trading back up
with the Lions so they can get chasey on
the three there's all kinds of things
that will happen but I'll be shocked if
if the Washington takes to it talking to
Peter King his column is football
morning in America you know keeping an
eye on some of these other quarterbacks
and as you said you know Brady is the
Domino
they're the next quarterback after Brady
is who in the Dominos well I think it
would be a tie I don't think there's
anybody who is overwhelming but I mean
teddy bridgewater is very interesting to
a bunch of teams because he's proved
isn't it in a good system he definitely
can win he's a great leader type guy and
so I mean whether that Tampa you know
which i think is probably the favorite
for Teddy Bridgewater and then after
that I guess you'd have to say cam
although in a good conversation with
Matt rule at the combine in e6 lad out
I'm really looking forward to working
with with Cam Newton and he's watched a
bunch of tape on him and I think right
he could guess right now my guess would
be to Carolina would lightly lightly
keep cam but that would not eliminate
them from taking say a Justin Herbert or
Jordan love maybe even trade down a bit
to do that in the first round and I mean
there there's any one of a number of
guys I I mean I think the big question
about Phillip Rivers right now is does
he really want to play regardless of
what the money is or is he going to be
out there seeking sort of franchise
quarterback money for a couple of years
and if they're a team like I kinda don't
think Indianapolis would do that I
thought for a while Indianapolis is the
favorite for for Philip Rivers but then
again if he wants 27 million a year I
doubt Indianapolis would pay that so
those are some of the issues right now
that are kind of floating out there was
there a guy who really and helped he
helped his draft stock at the combine I
don't know how much more that Isaiah
Simmons could do because most people
already thought he was a top 10 tech but
Justin in terms of impressive people and
players at the combine I would say that
Isaiah Simmons was number
because I mean I had I had a coach who
said Isaiah Simmons right now could walk
into his training camp he thinks and
place safety any linebacker spot or even
slaughter for me and so that would be
the most amazingly diverse did you know
it would be like the modern-day version
of Charlie Brown in New England you know
he can play so many places and then I
think the other guy was was Jonathan
Taylor the running back from Wisconsin
although Jalen hurts by the way had a
great night on Thursday I now think he's
an absolutely solid third-round pick a
lot of people love Jalen Hertz as a
leader and they really want him on their
team but I think they were concerned
about how he throws the deep ball
because he really has not had to throw a
lot of deep balls really and he threw
the deep ball again against air okay so
against no rushers but and he's got a
good arm so I don't know he helped
himself to but that running back from
Wisconsin wow this guy at 926 carries in
college but now you've got all these
people in the NFL who think well we may
not have a running back get to a second
contract anyway so let's just ride this
guy he's tremendous he's he's say Quan
esque so anyway we'll see yeah that's my
philosophy if I take a running back in
the first round I'm using him up those
five years and then that's it like I you
know even with the Cowboys I wouldn't
have recited zekiel Elliot you know I
would have found somebody else with that
offensive line
you know the Titans with what they have
with Derek Henry you know do you refine
him do you think he stays with Tennessee
well then that is a great question the
the gets it and look one of the reasons
why Tennessee has a huge vested interest
in which way does contract goes so
people who don't know this right now an
NFL team could could tag you know a
couple of free agents here in the last
year of the of this current CBA
but if there's a new CBA you can only
use one kite per year so if this passes
they've got Jack Conklin Derek Henry and
Ryan Tannehill and they can only tag one
so hmm I think I mean this is a tough
call if you're in on Tom Brady in my
opinion you've got a tag Derek Henry I
would if I were them and I would really
try hard to sign Coghlan but as crazy as
it sounds
Derek Henry is would be vitally
important if you're going hard after
braiding well if I'm Brady and by the
way he was facetiming Mike Vrabel from
the Syracuse game is that tampering
Peter I don't know I don't know the
answer to that they might have been
talking about no I don't think they're
breaking down buddy Bay Himes game you
know I by the way the Tony Romo deal
that seemed to steal the weekend what
was the buzz off of that
just that you know I think when you look
at what Romo did what what CBS did is
they wounded ESPN ESPN is not used to
losing things that they want to win
ESPN everybody in the business says
desperately wanted Romo and right now
the way you look at it is you know ESP
is because these packages Dan could
change just think about it in 2021
there's going if this passes there's
going to be 18 more football games could
10 of them be put in a package for
streaming
maybe with Google or Amazon or somebody
with a bottomless pit of money to throw
at the NFL you know a billion and a half
bucks for 10 okay games you know I
that's so you don't really know and you
hear all these things about ESPN wanting
to improve the Monday night package or
invade Sunday so I think what CBS did is
they said we are still a what I would
call it bejeweled property in the TV
field and we're not going to have our
biggest talent toast oh boy I still go
back to if Tony Romo didn't get hurt
like what what would he be doing today
what would the Cowboys have a
quarterback if that didn't happen well I
doubt they would have been so intent
that year that they went you know Dan
remember 2016 number one choice far and
away for the Dallas Cowboys Paxton Lynch
desperately disappointed when they
didn't get first pick of day three the
Cowboys thought that they had a trade
with the Cleveland Browns worked out
where they were going to trade up to get
this first pick in round four and they
were taking Connor cook
well they got trumped literally at the
last minute and Oakland traded up for
that ticket Oakland pick Connor cook and
then so as very in a very disappointed
way even though they had good reports on
dak Prescott they took that Prescott my
gut feeling just the gut feeling was it
Romo was healthy they wouldn't have been
so intent on getting a quarterback but
they a pig Prescott who knows maybe but
I doubt it and and and who knows Romo
you know what people don't know enough
about Tony Romo I'll never forget being
within a training camp one day and he
took out his phone and he had all these
videos of how every quarterback in the
league through and he was breaking down
everybody and it was a fun conversation
even if you're not a passing scientist
even if you're not hot house it was so
fun to listen to him and I remember
thinking that day because I always
thought Romo would be great on TV I did
not agree but I remember thinking that
day this guy breaking down the sport of
football in a way that people can
understand it
degree and you know you hate to say this
but as good as he was at his peak in
football you know he's better in the
booth Peter great great to read the
column as always thank you for your time
all the best and take care